mais on retrouve alexis bonnin qui est
donc toujours avec nous notre
éditorialiste alexiens débat qui s'ouvre
sans grandes chances d'aboutir si on
comprend bien oui malheureusement un
débat parce que on sent que ce débat
gène emmanuel macron finalement qui a
fait un virage à droite là on ne
l'attendait pas forcément est de plus en
plus à droite et que cette réforme
pourrait compliquer sa campagne pour
2022 et puis peut-être que lui
personnellement aussi n'a pas envie de
prendre position clairement il y en a
d'autres qui ont pris position
clairement sur ce débat qui mériteraient
beaucoup plus de temps puisque c'est un
débat moral éthique philosophique mêmes
qui demandent plus que quelques heures
dans une assemblée surchauffée où les
uns les autres ont déposé des dizaines
et des dizaines d'amendements
la réalité c est ce que l'état peut au
nom de la loi
terminez une vie et là par exemple
l'ancien garde des sceaux robert
badinter qui avait lutté 1 pour abolir
la peine de mort pour lui la réponse est
claire non l'état ne doit pas avoir
cette prérogative parce que là on ouvre
une porte extrêmement dangereuse même si
c'est soi disant pour le bien des
personnes et cette loi léonetti
justement essayer de faire la part des
choses en disant que la sédation
profonde
les soins palliatifs la lutte contre la
douleur et bien peuvent suffire pour
aider à la fin de vie plutôt que de
choisir un suicide assisté ou là on
rentre dans autre chose en termes de
droits mais aussi en termes de de la
façon dont l'état va traiter la personne
avec cette violence d'état qui pourra
être autre chose puisqu'elle pourra
donner la mort à nouveau et les médecins
aussi également un peu gêné par le
serment d'hippocrate qui doit les
empêcher évidemment de mettre fin à la
vie sauf si bien sûr il sait dans un
cadre des sédation profonde comme c'est
déjà été le cas et c'est déjà le cas
aujourd'hui l'idée c'est bien sûr
d'éviter les souffrances aux malades et
dans le reportage vous le disiez il ya
beaucoup trop
aujourd'hui deux territoires en france
qui n'ont pas les moyens nécessaires
pour avoir ces unités et permettre aux
malades en souffrance de d'abréger ses
souffrances et de quitter cette vie de
de la manière la plus apaisée possible
donc c'est un débat extrêmement complexe
qui touche tout le monde puisque nous
sommes tous amenés à mourir et qui
devrait provoquer davantage de débats
davantage aussi de réflexion que c'est
bien cette manoeuvre un peu politicienne
de dernier moment en disant qu'il faut
faire une réforme sociale et que ce sera
celle là il y avait aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs une autre réforme sociale qui
était dans les tuyaux qui n'a pas été
discuté et qui va aussi être portée
c'était celle sur la légalisation du
cannabis puisqu'on utilise aussi cette
drogue en matière thérapeutique pour
limiter les souffrances et aussi dans
certains dans certaines maladies
donc beaucoup de débats qui n'ont pas
lieu qui sont encore le lieu
d'affrontements politiciens alors que on
devrait la pour le cas élever le débat
est rentré dans une réflexion plus
profonde sur ce qu'est la fin de vie ce
qu'est aussi le rapport à la vie en
général parce que c'est vrai que si on
ouvre la porte à l'euthanasie alors
qu'est ce qui prouve que dans plusieurs
années
c'est pas pour raison économique qu'on
terminera la vie c'est pas pour d'autres
raisons qu'on terminera la vie et c'est
un débat qui dépasse le cadre simple de
la foi ou des religions merci avec six
poulains d'avoir été avec mon direct sur
rt france